good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson say what's that sound you hear
oh it's the sound of America getting a
little better you can feel it happening
last time we played you a clip from an
unintentionally hilarious MSNBC Town
Hall in which some pompous Airhead
reporter tries her best to explain to
Trump voters why January 6th actually
was an insurrection
an Insurrection in which only the police
had guns inside the capital Insurrection
which the police welcomed the
insurrectionists inside the building to
insurrect quite an Insurrection of
course the Insurrection that went
nowhere where the leader was dressed in
Viking horns eating psilocybin mushrooms
so we thought it was pretty funny what
we didn't note though last night was the
moment where that Airhead reporter
claims that a police officer was killed
by the mob that day
now if you watch television you've heard
that line so many times so many times
you may not even notice when people say
it anymore they've been saying it
constantly for nearly two years police
officers were killed many of them
why are they saying that it's not true
it's provably a lie it is in no sense
accurate No police officer was killed by
the mob on January 6th anyone who claims
otherwise is always welcome on this show
live to explain who exactly was killed
what's that officer's name and how was
he killed
we didn't expect any takers on that
offer
so the question is why do they keep
telling us that well there's a reason
there's always a reason they're telling
us that likely so we won't ask too many
questions the next time we read about
yet another January 6 protester going to
jail we'll just think oh another cop
killer getting what he deserves
that's what they're hoping you will
think and they're hoping that because if
you knew the truth if you knew why
they're really going to jail you'd be
very concerned
and here is the truth Joe Biden's
justice department is imprisoning people
for having the wrong thoughts thoughts
that we all imagined were
constitutionally protected as all
thoughts are
but don't take our word for it that's
such a right-wing talking point on our
cable channel you can read the court
filings in January 6th cases over the
past year and a half
and in virtually every instance Federal
prosecutors argue in public that the
political views of the defendants not
anything they actually did not crimes
they committed but instead their
personal beliefs what they think those
beliefs are reason enough to put them
behind bars
according to Joe Biden's doj for example
Army veteran Jessica Watkins needed to
be detained indefinitely because she had
quote extremist and violent views
regarding how to address what she
believed to be a fraudulent election oh
she was an extremist it's a term they
never explained but that apparently is
now a crime so we decide what extremist
means and then we put you in jail for
being one that's how that works UCLA
student Christian Secor that was the guy
who sat in Mike Pence's chair on January
6th is now in prison and he should be in
prison explain the Biden
administration's lawyers because he had
quote extremist beliefs and a quote
history of adhering to extremist
ideology really again you decide what
extremist is and then put me in prison
for being one
in the case of Robert Morris that was
the guy who was busted in possession of
a Lego set of the capital the doj put it
this way quote it is difficult to Fathom
a more serious danger to the community
than someone who tried to quote abort
the certification of a lawful and fair
election end quote it's the one kind of
abortion they don't favor the aborting
of a fair and free election
so in every case though the defendant's
real crime was not aborting an election
no the real crime in the doj says it
right in the filings
is denying the outcome of the election
it was believing the wrong thing it was
not believing that a senile man who
refused to leave his basement during the
campaign somehow got more votes than any
president in American history if you
refuse to believe that you're now a
felon
question the system and they haul you
away
those are the rules now as hundreds of
imprisoned Republicans can personally
testify if they could speak
so the legal precedent has been
established you cannot deny elections
and yet even in the face of the mounting
evidence this is now a very serious
felony there are some extremists who are
not deterred they're continuing to
commit the crime of election denial and
they're bold enough to do it on video
here ladies and gentlemen is one of them
I know we're all focused on the 2022
midterm elections and they are
incredibly important
but we also have to look ahead
because you know what our opponents
certainly are
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of it
the right wing controlled Supreme Court
may be poised to rule on giving State
legislatures Yes you heard me that
correctly State legislatures the power
to overturn presidential elections
did you hear that right-wing extremists
will literally literally must teach that
word in NPR literally steal the next
election
so that's preemptive election denial
committed by Hillary Clinton herself
but here's the thing probably not likely
that an FBI SWAT team is going to show
up at Hillary Clinton's house when she's
in the shower tomorrow morning
and in fact the next time a courthouse
is attacked in Portland Oregon or a
church is torched in downtown Washington
DC
it's unlikely that a doj court filing
will cite what Hillary Clinton just said
as an extremist ideology that led to
violence why is that well because in the
considered opinion of the democratic
party and the doj it's not election
denial when they do it no it's just
election affirming care
and there's been a lot of election
affirming care going around these past
few weeks in Washington
in the hometown newspaper owned by Jeff
Bezos The Washington Post Max boot just
announced that we're quoting if the
current trends hold up Republicans are
likely to take over at least the house
and quite possibly the Senate too along
with many State offices this is how
democracies die both at home and abroad
in other words
if you vote for the wrong person that's
not democracy which by the way unlike
dictatorship does not always come to the
conclusion that you favor
that's not democracy that's the death of
democracy democracy dies in both
darkness and non-liberal election
outcomes
oh okay
New York Magazine
isn't waiting around for the next
election here's their latest dispatch
quote there are already signs of 2020
election deniers refusing to accept
their own possible defeat this year
and that's half true of course but New
York Magazine isn't talking about
Republicans quote most observers are
primarily worried that Trump's 2020
Shenanigans may have served as a dress
rehearsal for 2024. wait what
what so that means you have Democrats
two years before the presidential
election telling us that that election
is going to be rigged
but that's not undermining confidence in
elections that's not an attack on our
sacred norms
not when it happens in New York Magazine
or at PBS which by the way you continue
to fund with your tax dollars the
channel nobody watches
when people watch PBS are the ones who
are stuck in traction and the attendance
going out for a cigarette and taking the
remote but they're still broadcasting
and here's what they're saying quote
nearly one in three Republican
candidates for Statewide office support
false election claims
so why aren't they in prison and what is
the end game of these dangerous
extremists led by Donald Trump will
Vanity Fair figure it out they blew the
plan wide open quote and then there's
Donald Trump Vanity Fair reported he
hasn't been implicated in any murders
that we know of nor is he currently
trying to kill anyone again that we know
of he is however said to be actively
plotting to steal the midterm elections
and the presidential one after that end
quote did you hear that
Donald Trump is going to steal the
midterm elections and then the
presidential election
how is he going to do that and isn't
predicting he's going to do that isn't
that itself a crime
we can't say we're not Merrick Garland
but we do know how he's going to do it
because Hillary Clinton's been giving
that away for years Donald Trump is
going to do that as he always has done
it with help from Vladimir Putin himself
watch we know the Russians
hack the DNC
hacked my campaign Etc Trump knows he's
an illegitimate president who got
illegitimate foreign health I do think
that he knows that he's an illegitimate
president I believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president you can run the
best campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you
[Applause]
and from you by Putin we better have a
nuclear war with him with him oh we're
moving toward that
too bad every Republican leader in
Washington is for how dumb are these
people but if you take three steps back
you will note that nothing the January 6
defendants have ever said even the guy
with the Viking horns on acid nothing
they've said is half as crazy as what
you just heard of Hillary Clinton say in
federal courtrooms January 6 defendants
are being sentenced to prison because
they're not exactly sure how it is that
Joe Biden got 15 million more votes than
Barack Obama did Barack Obama
the most the rock star who was president
and yet his vice president was so stupid
that even Barack Obama could barely
stand to be in the same room as him got
15 million more votes than he did how
did that work
how did Joe Biden get more votes than
any president in American history is
that not a fair question no it's not
it's a crime to ask and yet no one bats
an eye when Hillary Clinton tells us
that Putin is literally going to steal
the election
so how was it that only one side is
allowed to deny the results of elections
okay
no one answers that
here's Joe Biden claiming that Democrats
don't question election results
this is a nation that believes in the
rule of law
we do not repudiate it
this is the nation that respects free
and fair elections we honor the will of
the people we do not deny it
we do not deny it
unless of course two weeks out from a
pivotal midterm election we get the
sense based on polling that we're about
to be spanked like the Battle of girls
we are at which point we start making
excuses and planting the seeds for more
election denial just as we did after
Donald Trump won that's exactly what's
going on now even as they try to destroy
the careers
and tear down the character of people
who ask honest questions about the last
election and that would include Ron
Johnson who is the senator from
Wisconsin the Republican
one of the very few Republicans in the
entire U.S Senate who has actually
improved every year that he served there
as the opposite of the normal
progression for republicans in the
senate in case you haven't noticed now
Ron Johnson is running against someone
who's legitimately far out his name is
Mandela Barnes on Twitter Barnes once
rang in the New Year by praising and few
politicians do this by praising Iran's
Ayatollah because he supports BLM and
we're quoting the first tweet of 2015
from at Khamenei IR is black lives
matter let that sink in may this be a
most wonderful year for you and yours
Barnes wrote
so he's got the Ayatollah vote Barnes
also wants to abolish ice defund the
police and end cash bail so that would
result in further chaos in the total
Destruction of American society it might
be worth following up on that but no the
media in Wisconsin are still talking
about Ron Johnson's election denial
here's his hometown newspaper which no
one reads In fairness attacking him the
other day for it quote election deceiver
science fabulous billionaire benefactor
after 12 years is time to turn limit
Senator Ron Johnson
so again just to be clear
Democrats are sending people to prison
for questioning the last election trying
to prevent people from getting elected
in the midterm election for questioning
the last election while at the very same
time telling you that the 2016 election
was rigged the midterm will likely be
rigged and we know for a fact the 2024
election is not on the level
how does this work exactly
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight